[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti Sono Manfredi Rizza e
sono un atleta
e
ha un po' senso che venga un atleta a
parlare di tenacia perché
è facile associare a questa parola la
figura e la vita di un atleta
Anche perché
gli atleti sono nell'immaginario
collettivo queste figure ormai quasi
mitologiche tenaci forti dure
determinate che raggiungono il loro
obiettivo
con decisione
e
ed è facile forse per alcuni credo per
molti immaginare quanto duro lavoro ci
sia dietro a una performance sportiva
Anche perché molto spesso degli Atleti è
questo quello che si conosce la loro
performance e delle volte quando li
raggiungono i loro risultati
quello che però è un po' meno facile
forse per alcuni
immaginare e
quanto effettivamente sia faticosa la
vita di un atleta quanto sia in realtà
costellata di dubbi di incertezze di
momenti di insicurezza
per me è stato così io Ricordo ogni
mattina quando mi svegliavo L'unica cosa
a cui riuscivo a pensare era Spegni la
sveglia girati e torna a dormire cosa
stai facendo
vi parlo di una sveglia
nelle mattine invernali che solo Pavia
sa regalare quelli in cui ti giri verso
la finestra e semplicemente non vedi
nulla nebbia ovunque la mattina mi
svegliavo alle 5:00 alle 5:00 per per
andare al primo allenamento Allora
prendevo la mia Graziella e di corsa
d'allenamento per poi andare in stazione
e per andare a prendere il treno per
andare a Milano ehm in università dove
sarei rimasto tutto il giorno e poi di
nuovo su immaginatevi questa scena io
Graziella con due zaini Insomma un po'
una scena grottesca e per il secondo
allenamento
e così via tutti i giorni sempre stanco
di una stanchezza che ti sembra che
nessuno possa capire
e in quei due secondi in cui ti alzi ti
svegli e capisci dove sei Cosa sta
succedendo
realizzi una cosa che sei solo
completamente solo
e che sei stanco ma che il giorno dopo
non andrà meglio e neanche il giorno
successivo
realizzi che quella però è la strada che
hai scelto quella è la strada che
riflette le tue ambizioni
e che devi tenere duro perché nessuno
farà quelle cose al posto tuo e ogni
allenamento ogni passo
è come l'anello di una catena che se si
spezza fa crollare la catena
perseverare credere nel processo Questa
è la parte difficile
essere denari tenaci o costanti Se
volete significa ogni giorno fare
piccoli passi compiere Piccole scelte
quotidiane che sommate nei giorni nei
mesi negli anni ti portano a raggiungere
i tuoi obiettivi
rimandare la sveglia o alzarsi dal letto
mangiarsi una pizza o prepararsi un
pranzo sano uscire con gli amici o
dormire un paio d'ore in più andare a
lezione o saltarla
tirare in allenamento anche se si è
stanchi o non farlo
ma non puoi prendere queste decisioni
ogni giorno se non credi che ciò che
stai facendo sia qualcosa di concreto di
reale di realizzabile Se non credi che
le tue scelte sono guidate da un
obiettivo e non da un sogno
E allora come si fa Qual è la chiave che
apre le porte alla tenacia
per me è stato il coraggio Non
fraintendete non sto parlando di del
coraggio che si legge nei romanzi o che
si vede nei film quello delle grandi
geste eroiche sto parlando di qualcosa
di semplice di
piccolo
quel qualcosa che
in realtà tutti noi abbiamo Ma che non
sempre ascoltiamo perché ci costa molta
fatica
sto parlando del coraggio che mi ci è
voluto per darmi degli obiettivi
ambiziosi
del coraggio che mi ci è voluto per
ammettere i miei difetti a mettere i
miei limiti a mettere i miei errori
accettarli perché se non sai da dove
parti non sai che strada non sai che
strada devi intraprendere
parlo del coraggio che ci vuole nel dare
il 100% in ciò che si sta facendo
il coraggio che ci vuole per perseguire
il proprio obiettivo
e ancora non basta perché la vita
ci mette di fronte a degli imprevisti
delle volte è in ritardo di Trenitalia
Delle volte una pandemia che mette in
ginocchio il mondo non lo puoi sapere
e gli imprevisti vanno affrontati
Nel 2020 nonostante il lockdown e la
pandemia E tutto quello che è successo
sono riuscito a laurearmi in ingegneria
dei materiali
sono riuscito a mantenere la forma con
sforzi e sacrifici importanti ma tutto
stava in qualche modo filando abbastanza
bene Ero carico erogasato ero pronto per
intraprendere l'ultimo l'ultima stagione
quella che mi avrebbe portato poi alle
Olimpiadi di Tokyo
ma proprio in quel momento ad ottobre
quando dovevamo ricominciare io il mio
allenatore a lavorare per l'anno nuovo
mi sono ammalato di covid
ero ero a terra
la convalescenza per vari motivi è
durata quasi un mese So che può non
sembrare tanto ma un mese in uno sport
di prestazione come il mio molte volte
significa fine dei giochi
ero depresso demotivato
e mi sentivo vecchio
ma
in quel momento nel momento di massima
paura quando ho veramente temuto che
sarebbe finito tutto che non sarei
riuscito ad andare alle Olimpiadi
figuriamoci prendere una medaglia
decisi che non mi volevo arrendere
decisi che non mi interessava cosa non
avevo fatto Cosa non avrei potuto fare
ho deciso di concentrarmi solo su me
stesso solo sul presente
quello che successe è che
dopo mesi in realtà di dubbi di
incertezze di
momenti anche un po' di sconforto
cominciai a migliorare e più pensavo
solo a me stesso più miglioravo
e ed era come se tutta tutta
quella incertezza tutte quelle paure
tutte tutte le mie insicurezze
unite però alla mia voglia di non
arrendermi
mi avessero reso più forte
e quel giorno mi hanno permesso di
realizzare la gara più bella della mia
vita che vorrei condividere con voi
per la partenza
la tensione che sale le togna Spagna
Gran Bretagna Ungheria Italia - Svezia
Spagna partiti con una buona partenza di
Manfredi di ottima partenza di Sandokan
in acqua 4 lungherese bene anche Rizza
in acqua sei sono 200 metri da vivere in
apnea Rizza in terza posizione in questo
momento siamo con i 171 colpi al minuto
per l'azzurro di Pavia Rizza Prova a
puntare la prima posizione c'è stando a
toccare davanti rissa però tienila al
secondo posto in linea con Lyon fit e
Carlos arrivava allo sta recuperando
Rizza in acqua sei l'Italia l'azzurro
recupera i centimetri su centimetri su
di ungherese va a chiudere lì con il
podio vediamo di che colore sarà
e questo è il risultato
[Musica]
Grazie
[Applauso]
però vedete
quello che ho capito
Alla fine di tutto alla fine del
percorso
è che quella medaglia è soltanto un
pezzo di metallo
ciò per cui ho lavorato strenuamente
senza sosta per anni arrivati a questo
punto non ha poi tanto valore perché ciò
che ho ottenuto non è una medaglia non è
la gratificazione per i miei sforzi Cioè
è anche quello ma non solo e ho ottenuto
qualcosa di più prezioso di molto più
importante
ho ottenuto un modo di vivere un modo di
essere
durante questo percorso sono sono
cambiato sono passato da essere un
ragazzino svogliato pigro
ha ormai non più un ragazzo quasi adulto
diciamo
determinato coraggioso
che non ha paura di dare il 100% e non
ha paura di fallire
E allora
è un po' questo quello che io Auguro a
voi per le vostre vite non tanto di
raggiungere i vostri obiettivi quello
non è importante
ma di diventare persone che hanno il
coraggio di essere tenaci persone che
hanno il coraggio di fare ciò che serve
per raggiungere il proprio obiettivo
E se lo farete
non importa se raggiungerete o meno il
vostro obiettivo perché saprete di aver
dato il cento per cento e non avrete
rimpianti Grazie mille
[Applauso]